the most popular show on television
HBO's Game of Thrones is just two
episodes away from the series finale
more than 12 million people watched the
show on TV and another 5 million watch
on other platforms but for fans who fall
behind the risk of spoilers is real
Jonathan Vigliotti takes a look and we
assure you he does not have any spoilers
for devoted fans unable to catch last
night's episode of Game of Thrones
avoiding spoilers may feel like its own
epic battle why does it anger you so
much because I because it ruins the
whole the roller-coaster ride the
experience and then you see it in a
different way it's like before you walk
into your surprise party someone tells
you you're gonna have to walk into your
surprise party but keeping plot twists
secret has become nearly impossible in
this digital age consider this there
were seven point eight million tweets
about last week's episode the long night
making it the most tweeted about episode
in TV history
you come those who've loved other
popular shows like breaking bad The
Sopranos and lost see Internet
abstinence is the only way to protect
yourself you can even go on your phone
you can't go on the internet you can't
do anything spoilers have gotten so bad
that directors of the blockbuster hit
Avengers end game used the a-list cast
to encourage audiences to keep quiet
don't spoil the ending we are in a hyper
sensitive environment for spoilers and
if you spoil something on the internet
social media will let you have it even
journalists have to be careful the
problem that outlets have is when they
give away something in a headline or a
sub-headline
where they really don't want to know and
you've told them
but most fans agree in a world where
jaw-dropping plot twists rule the screen
it's hard to keep secrets for long like
you were confessing to having spoiled
things before you know even those
pictures though I haven't seen the last
few and I thought they might it all work
it out over like some cups of chamomile
tea so it turns out there was a conflict
well I am a huge game of thrones I've
read the first two books I have not seen
any of episodes the seasons I've just
for some reason I've been busy but I am
gonna get on the treadmill in the next
couple days and I'm just gonna but I
just think guys once it's out there how
can you not talk about it I know I just
like Breaking Bad yeah and I just
thought once it's out there I just think
it's unfair that people just can't talk
about it anymore so it's on I just
didn't well yeah and or didn't watch
that story and this is a nice segue to
our next piece